so my question is basically i'm kind of
tired of banging low quality women what
kind of women are you dating right now
i'm dating a 42 year old single mom dude
for the last five years what do you do
for a living and where do you live i'm
like a fine dining waiter and i as a
side hustle i day trade how much money
do you make on an annual basis roughly
40k annually annually 40k what do you
think your problem is i'm very smart but
i feel like at times when i'm the
spotlight's on me i sort of don't really
articulate myself and it kind of comes
off as unconfident we've got looks money
status game how's your game sucky status
still working on it money and money i
think i'm doing pretty well for myself
and looks you got looks covered so
you're missing out on three main areas
right like you want to be influential
right you got to get yourself leveled up
to the next level i mean that's why
you're grabbing low-hanging fruit like
42 year old single mother you want the
dime pieces you can't rest on your
laurels as difficult as it might be to
take this jagged little pill you're not
good enough for dime pieces